I hate intra as my hero academia sees in
three you don't need to worry about
Episode one cuz that's just a recap
episode and a swimming contest I hope
they don't do this reason for otherwise
this videos gonna be pointless yepez ode
to DOMA does discuss in the next move
with code oh goodie ketone arrives to
let them know that the shipment from the
Union will arrive tomorrow so it looks
like they're planning on something big
the students go on a summer training
camp where they meet up with mandalite
and the other post cam member helping
with the training Pixie Bop for the
first test picks he makes earth monsters
for the students to fight off while they
walk through the forest to the place
where they're gonna be staying for the
training camp after that they meet Kota
who is an angsty little kid who dislikes
heroes because his parents were heroes
and died to a villain you know dia
notices this and seems drawn to changing
his mind the episode 3 everyone is
working hard on improving their quirks
and we're introduced to the two other
members of the Pussycats ragdoll who
knows about people just by looking at
them and the fourth member Tiger who
just fights well everybody's eating Kota
slips off to a secret hideout because he
doesn't want to associate with any
heroes he still needs to eat though soma
DoDEA goes to bring him some food we
thought he tries talking to him but
typical angsty kid just tells him off we
get a look at dobby and the other
villains planning to attack the students
they launch their attack during the test
of courage with both Class A and Class B
participating when the attack is
launched mitho do you realize is that
Kota is actually alone in his secret
spot episode 4 eraser he gets word of
the attack but when he goes to help you
stop by dobby the students in the woods
have to find a way to avoid poison smoke
while the pussycat square off against
magnae who was threatening to kill Pixie
Bop spitter is still clinging to the
ideologies of the hero killer stain and
ends up getting into a fight with the
Pussycat member Tiger radio DJ gets
Dakota who has already ran into one of
the villains muscular who was ironically
the villain that killed Cody's parents
[ __ ] ago was out on the test of courage
as well and he was paired up with Toto
too they both run into the villain
moonfish who was playing with the
severed arm
[Music]
after a drawn-out fight me thought he
ends up going all-out on muscular trying
to protect Koda and knocks him
unconscious go at that sees how hard
he's trying to spite how badly injured
he is which makes him start to come
around to the idea of Heroes episode 5
we find out the villains main target is
buck ago he racer fights off dobby but
it's actually just a clone made by the
other villain twice just to be clear
that's his name he didn't make the clone
twice see you racer runs into me the
audience adds a message with him to tell
Mandalay that all the students seem to
protect themselves since they are the
ones being targeted courtesies that he's
been a bit of a douche and once you
apologize to midoriya Bakugan thought oh
look he continued their fight with
moonfish while Tetsu targets the source
of the poison smoke with the help of its
Cod they take out the kid responsible
and the smoke starts to disperse while
me Dougherty is looking for Baku go he
is intercepted by Shoji Shoji tells him
that they have to figure out what to do
about Toki ami who lost control of dark
shadow because it's nighttime Yepez owed
six
wellmy daughter yen Shoji are trying to
figure out what to do about dark shadow
PACU go and Totoro keaur stillness tell
me it with moonfish Shoji uses his perk
to lure dark shadow to the ongoing fight
and dark shadow subdues moon fish they
then use the light from a fire to weaken
dark shadow and calm it down a check who
gets stabbed in the arm while fighting
the blood loving yawn today Hema gotaga
not the typical bodily fluid that girls
cry but a soui and a choco work together
to fight against it when we thought he
and the others arrived Tok asked to
leave but not before falling in love
with your boy mister comprised Steel's
Bakugan Tokyo me with this perk and then
runs away
Momo makes a tracker and they manage to
get it on the Nomo who attacked them we
thought he Shoji in toto Doki you so
chose power to slingshot and tackle
mister compress but they land in front
of all the villains episode 7 the three
of them fight with the villains to try
and get Bakugan Tokyo me back they
managed to get back one of the orbs
which was Tokyo me but the villain still
managed to get back ago in the aftermath
15 students were in serious condition
from the gas pixie Bob took his shots at
the head in his in serious condition and
ragdoll lost a lot of blood and is
missing muscular mustard and moon fish
were the only villains captured the
media comes at you way harder than ever
for the recent failures there also might
be a spy in the pro hero group because
nobody knew about the training camp
except for the select teachers class a
stops by to see Mendota yet when he
wakes up good as Shima overheard all my
talking with mama about the tracker she
put on the Nomo and suggests having her
make another one so that they can go and
get Baku go back yep a Saudi
I thought he learns that if he injures
his arms as badly two or three more
times his arms are gonna stop working
the cops rally the troops for the
mission to get Baku go back with heroes
including endeavor best genus gang Gorka
Gran Torino tiger I guess the other post
Casper - irrelevant Lal Kamui woods and
mountain lady we go do toto ducky Momo
and Kirishima I decided to try and
retrieve Baku go without fighting
because the school's reputation is on
the line he needs to ensure that there
isn't any fighting so eita goes along -
once they get their disguises do they
start heading over to go get Baku go
though Matt tries convincing Baku go to
join the villains but Google refuses and
gives him a good smack that cancels out
his facepalm the episode not we get a
quick look at Toma to his master all for
one meanwhile a media and the others
find the hideout that the tracker led
them to and when they look inside they
find a bunch of no moves the pro here's
who had the actual location of Baku go
watch their attack on the village and
quickly restrain them mountain lady and
best genus end up assaulting the nomu
hideout where me thought he is and
secure the Nomos and the missing Kuro
right doll it looks like a clean win but
then portals deliver a bunch of Nomos
who helped the villains buyback Baku
Goins up getting taken by one of the
portals we jump back a couple of minutes
with best genius a mountain lady being
approached by a mysterious figure and
tried to restrain him yep - so Ted the
heroes are forced to fight against the
gnome who said all might leaves to go
help Jaden send the amazonian who were
taken out by all for one buck ago and
the villains are all transported there
using the portals all my shows up I
can't get to baka go because all-4-one
is keeping him busy
all-4-one opens a portal for the rest of
the villains to escape they are trying
to capture about Gugu before they leave
but Authority and the others use a plan
to save him all-4-one forces the
villains to escape but stays behind to
cover the retreat he episode 11 we get
some flashbacks of all mites master in
nana schemata who was killed by
all-4-one we also find out that the
villain Tomita is the grandson of humour
doc the puppet finally see all my true
form because he can't maintain his
muscle form in the fight against all
four 104 one has been trying to soften
him up until now but prepares to deliver
the final blow
oh my has to expend the remainder of his
powers to subdue all-4-one in his final
mission as the number on
well for the episode well we learned
that she might I put her son into foster
care to protect him after her husband
was killed and that's how all for one
was able to get to it in response of the
recent incident the school sets up a new
dorm system for the students to help
keep them safe eraser and all might go
to the students houses to help commits
the parents of the students to let them
stay in the dorms
everyone seems on board and told me
DoDEA's mom says no but after some
convincing from mom might she comes
around to the idea
episode 13 the students all move into
their new dorms the principle states
that it's also possible for there to be
a spy amongst the students as well the
rest of the episode is just the filler
of them showing up how they decorated
their rooms the episode 14 with the
students officially moved into the dorm
so they have to start thinking about
getting their provisional hero license
to help them prepare for the test the
teachers help them come up with new
ultimate moves Authority it goes with
IVA and who they're not going to make
some modifications to their suit say me
with power loader he's gonna be doing
the modifications along with the help of
one of his students may hots me while
doing this my daughter he doesn't come
up with a new ultimate move but he does
decide to switch to using his legs
instead of his arms to fight the episode
15 everyone arrives at the provisional
license test where they compete with
other schools for the licenses they meet
with some of the schools that they're
gonna be competing against and after are
told what the first competition is of
the fifteen hundred and forty applicants
only one hundred will make it through to
the next round each contestant has three
targets put on them and if the three
targets get hit with playing balls and
they are out and they need to eliminate
two people to advance one of the
traditions at the provisional license
exam is for all the other schools to
gang up on you at the beginning when the
game starts total rookie goes off by
himself in Baku ko goes with Kirishima
everyone else ends up getting surrounded
by all the other schools
episode 16 Yoshino crumbles to ground
beneath you a and in the chaos he gets
separated you know see Yoda she uses his
wing quirk to steal a bunch of balls and
pelts everybody beneath them knocking
out 120 people which makes hims the
first to advance come you see me can
turn invisible and hits one of my
daughter's targets I was rooting for
Medea but I don't know after saying this
I kind of want her to win before it can
go any further they get interrupted by a
group of students who thought - you save
zero daca but knows she's actually a
faking disguise the real daca and said
Oh show up to help him fight off the
faith go to Loki who is still by himself
ends up getting targeted by says you in
high school students who share my
ability to make their small things grow
yep - sewed 17 go todo Qiao plays the
censured students and is the first you a
student to make it through to the next
round who sue ejido MoMA and Shoji are
trapped in a room by the CI Academy
students and are being frozen
Momo makes some big grand plays creating
an amp and headphones which allows judo
to emit a high-frequency attack
disabling them and letting all four
advance of the next round
Goethe Shima gets turned into a blob I
say she should Goethe sobaka go has to
start fighting with him mytho do Daka
and Seto are still being chased by cats
of bhutesu students episode 18 baka go
Falls for a trap and has turned into a
blob also leaving just community left to
fight he uses a new move with the
equipment he got from power loader to
take down says all of the other people
who turned into blobs turned back and
the three of them had to fight them up
but end up making it through to the next
round vodka go dada kencho-ji set up
their own trap which secures them going
into the next round with not many spots
left yama shoots his napal laser into
the air which rallies the rest of the ua
students for one big showdown where all
of them make it through to round two
episode 19 for stage two the
battleground from stage 1 is blown up
and people act like victims I need to be
saved
students get points deducted if they
handle a situation in the wrong way
everyone is doing pretty well until game
Gorka shows up to play a villain
attacking the city Yepez owed 20 is a
filler episode that happened over summer
vacation episode 21 it's revealed that
another big part of how they're being
graded is cooperation gang Gorka starts
to move but is intercepted by toto dokie
aunty nothi their attacks cancel each
other out and they won't coordinating
I'd say hates Toto Doki and his dad
after getting messed up by gang Gorka
and yelled at by mediodía they put their
differences aside and coordinates
attract gang Gorka in a fiery tornado
with the evacuation is finishing up the
others come to help with the fight but
the test as before any real blows can
land the names of the passing students
are posted but we don't see those until
next episode episode 22 the list is
revealed and everybody passes except for
Baku go Toto Doki and Inasa you know as
he comes over to apologize for Miki Toto
Doki fail and total Doki also apologizes
they still don't seem to like each other
but they're on okay terms luckily
they're failing students can still get
their license once they take a
three-month course now that they have
their license students can conduct hero
work during emergency situations only we
find out that the girl who turned into
Oda daca and file with me door to go was
actually the villain toga her quark is
that she can transform into anybody she
wants after she ingest their blood while
fighting with me doggy actually managed
to get some of his blood so keep that in
mind for the future
all-4-one is being held in a prison but
doesn't seem like he's intending on
staying there long
[ __ ] who go figure it out the media got
his power from all my because ragdoll
lost her court to all for once since he
found out that courts could be passed
down and taken he figures that's what
happened with me dodea in the last scene
he gets me dodea alone and challenges
him to a fight episode 23
we thought again of course doesn't want
a fire but Bakugan tax anyways forcing a
defense it's revealed that Baku Co feels
responsible for all my losing his powers
because he got kidnapped these feelings
have reached a boiling point so he's
fighting as a coping mechanism with Odia
fights back in an intent to make him
feel better and ends up losing
oh my head overheard them and it comes
out to explain that bow coogo isn't
responsible for him losing his powers
[ __ ] ago agrees to keep the secret and
both of them get house arrest and
cleaning duties as punishment for
fighting episode 24 in light of all
mites retirement crime activity has been
slowly getting worse where you get a
little backstory on the villain twice
his quirk allows him to duplicate things
so he made a bunch of clones of himself
and they all got into a fight over who
the real one was and killed each other
now he isn't sure if he's actually the
real one and he hears voices we get a
glance at some of the new villains on
the move the students will be able to
participate in another program like the
intern one but having more to do with
hero work and finally we meet the
third-years who are at the top of the
school also known as the big three
episode 25 the big three are there to
talk about the program since they took
part in it meteo decides that fighting
everybody at the same time will help
with this explanation and ultimately
make it faster it can go through any
object and uses this to make quick work
of the class we thought he is the only
one to even come close to landing a blow
and meteo says that sir might like him
after the fight he monologues a bit
about the program and we are introduced
to sir who was tracking the villain from
earlier overhaul the league of villains
is trying to recruit overhauled who
apparently is pretty strong with both
sides ramping up only time will tell
who's gonna come out on top it's
mediodía Midori is gonna win I don't
know I was just trying to do an epic
outro